vous entendez ce sont des flamants roses
il y en a partout autour de moi je suis
en camargue au parc ornithologique du
pont de gau des flamants roses en
liberté ou cigales de louper ces grands
oiseaux
il mesure 1 m 60 tout en étant léger
comme une plume pas plus de 3 kg et puis
leur couleur rose
on a l'impression qu'ils sont tombés
dans un pot de peinture allez suivez moi
l'atelier on va éclaircir tout ça pas
trop quand même hein parce qu'ils sont
jolis en rose un flamand ne n'est pas
rose mais avec un duvet gris ce duvet
s'éclaircit puis les plumes pouces
blanches avec des extrémités noir au
bout des ailes oiseaux ne se colore
vraiment qu'au fil du temps
en grandissant et c'est au bout de trois
ans environ lorsqu'il devient adulte
qu'un flamand rose est enfin aux
flamands
flament flamande qui vient de flandre
mais non loiseau le flamant rose s'écrit
avec un thé à la fin et non avec un dé
comme les flamands les habitants des
flandres le nom flamand rose trouve son
origine dans l'occitan flamenca qui veut
dire flammes
il fait référence évidemment à la
couleur flamboyante de cette famille
d'oiseaux
les flamands qui compte six espèces d'un
rose plus ou moins soutenu et ce n'est
pas malgré son nom le flamant rose le
plus rose de tous mais son cousin le
flamand des caraïbes dont les plumes
vire carrément au rouge corail mais
comment fabrique t il ce rose si
particulier grâce à leur nourriture
allez on file au resto bien alors qu'est
ce qu'on mange ici des algues
microscopiques de petits crustacés et
également des petits mollusques cette
nourriture est très abondant dans ce
tour vaseuses et salé elle est également
très riche en caroténoïdes rapidement
rouge orangé le même que celui qu'on
retrouve dans les carottes au cours d'un
digestion les flamands 5 qui ces
pigments et l'absorbent pour le retrouve
ensuite dans les graisses dans les
pattes et au niveau des ailes mais comme
si ça ne suffisait pas les flamands ici
rajoute une couche je vous montrais les
flamands roses fabrique temple est une
substance grasse et un rose bien sûr
qu'il récupère au niveau d'une glande
située sous leur croupion le croupion
soul croupion y puisent de la grèce avec
leur bec au niveau de cette zone
je sais c'est bizarre puis il lisse leur
plume ajoutant ainsi un maquillage
lustrant et rose sur leur plumage déjà
color il ya cependant un moment dans la
vie du flamand ou sa couleur change
lorsqu'ils élèvent son unique petit de
l'année au printemps il pas lisse car à
ce moment là les parents fabrique et
régurgite une sorte de l'aide du lait de
jabot comme l'on dit très concentré en
caroténoïdes pour justement que nourrir
le petit si bien qu'au bout de plusieurs
semaines de nourrissage bien il n'est
pas rare de voir leurs plumes devenir
quasiment blanche
normal puisque les caroténoïdes sont
utilisés pour nourrir le petit chaque
hiver des flamants roses se regroupent
pis si pour la parade nuptiale 1 après
20 minutes longues nous pendant
plusieurs semaines mâles et femelles
exécutent des chorégraphies très codifié
pour se séduire les uns les autres pour
former des couples qui vont durer le
temps d'une saison ou même temps de
faire un point ça alors les
scientifiques ont observé hui posture et
bissett enseignement différent ce qui
fait un total de 136 combinaisons
du coup l'hiver est la meilleure saison
pour observer les pékin où certains
appellent les flamands à provence parce
qu'en plus d'avoir une couleur
particulière
ils ont aussi vous l'aurez sûrement
remarqué un bec très particulier pour
des oiseaux qui vivent les pieds dans
l'eau avec recourbées vers le bas régime
strict pour se nourrir le flamant rose
plonge la tête d' angles puis il
recourbe le coup et il avance la tête à
l'envers
c'est finalement le hot son bec qui rate
le sol vaseux
un peu comme on le fait avec une
épuisette ça fonctionne un peu comme une
cafetière à piston le fond de la
cafetière correspond au dessus de son
bec et le piston à sa langue
le flamand fait rentrer de l'eau qui
contient de la nourriture dans son bain
puis il appuie avec sa langue comme on
appuie avec le piston l'eau
et chasser sur les côtés par de petits
orifices
on les voit bien ici ces petits orifices
que l'on compare souvent aux fans ont de
la baleine il appuie long qu'avec sa
langue
l'eau est chassé puis il récupère la
nourriture sur sa langue et il n'a plus
qu'un valet il a même développé une
technique bien à lui on peut le voir
parfois tourner en rond autour de son
bec plonger dans l'eau en renault c'est
pas dans le sol
les cercles qu'il laisse derrière lui
elles sont un vice de son passage et ce
n'est pas tout regardez ils tiennent sur
une patte ou ou au compliqué pour nous
pas pour un flamand installé sur une
patte et dormir c'est même la position
la plus reposante pour ce genre d'oiseau
je vais vous montrer tout est une
affaire d' équilibre dans cette position
unijambiste l'une des pattes et repliée
sous les ailes tandis que l'autre se
trouve pile à la verticale du centre de
gravité de l'animal et les muscles de sa
patte porteuse ne sont donc pas tendu
par les forts contrairement à ce que
l'on pourrait penser mais au repos le
flamand ne fatigue pas du tout à tel
point que même mort
le flamant rose peut tenir debout dans
cette position alors pour réaliser une
telle prouesse l'oeuf la mort peut
compter sur sa cheville
eh oui l'articulation que l'on voit au
milieu de la pâte
ici c'est sa cheville le jeune où ils se
cachent au niveau du corps là et c'est
lui qui s'oublie soul elle quand
l'oiseau tient sur une patte en somme
pour lui tenir sur une seule patte c'est
comme être à genoux y est allé j'y
retourne parce que c'est vraiment une
histoire à dormir debout
à bientôt mâles et femelles exécute des
des se cache genou
ce cash
[Musique]